My name is Harry Yeff, my artist name is
Reeps One. I'm here at Harvard University taking
part in a few lectures: phonetics, talking about creative
process and the human voice. Of course
there's my speaking voice and the thing
I'm using to communicate now but there
is a palette of hundreds and hundreds of
other pressures and sounds which are not
only unique but you can interconnect
them. They can start interacting and
working together so you can have
percussion and melody happening at the same
time. And this is something that isn't
common in physical instruments, so I found
a freedom in the voice I can't achieve
with other instruments, and that's why I
fell in love with it originally.
I am teaching Linguistics 105 which is sounds
of language. Language is a highly
systematic, subconscious system. The same
thing happens with beatboxing: it's
subconscious people develop it. The
brain systematizes sounds that they
make for a musical effect. I think that's
just fantastic for the students to see
both of those angles. You can have a
hundred kids anywhere in the world and
they can't and get access to instruments
but they can start learning percussion
immediately. You can learn drum theory
with the voice, you can learn a piece that
you're playing on the violin with the
voice. Speaking about how that's
effectively creative is the main goal.
People don't realize what they can do what
their potential is, and sometimes it can
be something as simple as an art form
to show that there are still new things
to be discovered, and I really love that
sentiment. If at any point an artist or
musician can show there's a new way of
thinking about something or a new way of
doing something or finding a new palette of
the voice, I think that has purpose and is
beneficial, and I would love to send that message.